stern faces all round thank you for
saying thank you for seeing me beware
the vice president said at one stage the
meeting didn't so much concern but the
bravado from both sides may have been
what got them round this table and for
around five hours they thrashed out an
agreement that both good conscience and
Vice President of the United States Mike
Pence was already delightedly tweeting
about how his tough love had got the
deal done I'm proud to report thanks to
the strong leadership of President
Donald Trump and the strong relationship
between president air dhawan and Turkey
and the United States of America that
today the United States and Turkey have
agreed to a ceasefire in Syria the
agreement means the fighting which was
very long hours before the announcement
will be halted for a hundred and twenty
hours whilst the Kurdish YPG forces came
back about 20 miles from the Turkish
border just what the Turkish president
it's no ceasefire their foreign ministry
insisted but a pause and down to their
strong negotiator who can COO who's our
killer they're talking to Sky News this
rule the Turkish conditions were laid
out bare again by the vice president
nations this is the buffer zone in you
try hard borders and they got it the
next stage will be moving refugees in
there the pause in fighting was said by
the Americans to have been welcomed by
the Kurdish forces in reality as they
try to cope with their wounded they'll
feel this gives the Turks exactly what
they sought to achieve with their
military operation in the first place
and the man who they believe betrayed
them was claiming credit for it you
would have lost millions and millions of
lives they couldn't get it without a
little rough love as I called it I just
put out they needed a little bit of that
at the beginning that rough love
probably referred to the assumptions
which the Turkish insisted wouldn't make
any difference anyway and which will now
be directed
but Syrian regime forces are also now in
the area alongside Russian soldiers and
there's the Islamic state presence this
agreement leads so many questions
unanswered and the Kurds almost
certainly feeling they've been betrayed
a second time by their former partners
Alex Crawford Sky News in Turkey